i don't know if you remember lizzo lizzo
is like a larger
pop culture figure she's sort of famous
for
being a big girl is the phrase that she
uses and she's a singer
it talks about body positivity and all
this
lizzo just got in trouble
because i kid you not she went on a diet
monday december 21st the historical
docuseries apollo 11 what we saw
will be available exclusively at
dailywire.com this takes a detailed look
at the apollo 11 mission to land a man
on the moon it's a terrific series
to watch with your loved ones over the
christmas season the way i think about
these three categories conservatism
liberalism and leftism or wokism or
whatever is the conservatism
says you should follow the conservative
moral standard
and respect conservative institutions
the traditional institutions
and maybe have some deference toward
your forebears and the founding fathers
and
your parents and have some loyalty and
have some patriotism and
recognize your duty in this world that's
kind of the conservative view then the
leftist view is just like a flip of that
which is you should follow the new
leftist radical politically correct
moral order
you should feel entitlement you should
feel uh sort of
disdain for the past because the past
was bad and the future is better so you
should feel really good about yourself
and about the future
but you should hate the past and and
basically have the opposite of
patriotism have disdain for your country
because you're going to move into this
wonderful future but they are
sort of parallel ideas they're just a
mirror image of one another
and then in the middle you have
liberalism and liberalism says
do what you want do what you want if it
feels good do it
if it's not bothering anybody you know
and it's not
affecting the politics and it's just
private then just do whatever you want
now the reason that liberalism is
unstable is of course because the things
that we do that we sometimes pretend are
private
do have political effects a good example
of this is if uh
gender or the gender ideology i'm a man
but i say i
i now identify as a woman okay that's a
private choice but it has a public
effect
because now i'm going to go use the
women's bathroom well am i allowed to do
that obviously affects other people
now i'm going to insist that everyone
else call me
a woman call me she well now i'm
infringing on someone else's private
choice all right but it's my pride so
whose private choice gets to win
obviously these private choices
have a public effect and it's so it's
it's the liberalism
that we're talking about today is pretty
incoherent but it's very very
popular and it goes off the rails real
real quick
lizzo this sort of larger performer went
on a diet last month
she is i'm not in any way making fun of
the way she looks or anything but she is
objectively
not that healthy you know it is not
healthy to carry around that much weight
and so if she's going to do something
for her she said she had these physical
symptoms
that go along with her kind of the way
she had been eating so she decided she
wants to
just fix those symptoms and feel a
little bit better
so she goes on a diet and people were
furious
because she is supposed to embrace
whatever lifestyle she wants
and she never mind that she's changed
what lifestyle she wants
now they're saying no you you you're kim
to fame
as the pro-fat pro body positivity
woman and so you need to remain fat you
need to
pursue your own appetites to their
extreme and never even think
about changing them and you know what
lizzo did after she went on this diet
she apologized i did the 10-day smoothie
detox and
as you know i would normally be so
afraid
and ashamed to post things like this
online because i feel like as a big girl
people just expect
if you are doing something for health
you're doing it for like a dramatic
weight loss
and that is not the case um in reality
november stressed me the [ __ ] out i
drank a lot i ate a lot of spicy things
and things that
my stomach up and i wanted to reverse it
and get
back to where i was i'm so proud of
myself i'm proud of my results
um my sleep has improved my hydration
my inner peace my mental stability my
body my [ __ ] skin the whites my eyes
like i feel and look like a bad [ __ ]
and i think like that's it i'm a big
girl
who did a smoothie detox and i wanted to
share that with you guys i got exactly
what i wanted out of it
and every big girl should do whatever
they want with their bodies
this is very confusing because on the
one hand he's saying
the thing i did to get healthier really
felt good and i feel really great about
it but also you should do whatever the f
you want with your body
well if you're saying it makes you feel
better and it's good then why don't you
recommend that to other people
and why this confessional approach i'm
sorry i
went on a diet i'm sorry i'm sorry you
know seriously when when catholics
when catholics confess their sins they
go to a confessional right just like you
see in the movies you go into the
confessional there's the priest there
and he said tell me your sins
one sin that you when you're making your
examination of conscience and you
confess
a sin is gluttony this isn't gluttony is
a sin
drinking too much is a sin and if you've
been
eating a little too much maybe you're
stress eating i don't know i've been
stressing a lot a lot going on
in the last couple months uh that that
that can be sinful
if you do that willfully and so you
would confess it and this
is just the exact flip of that it's like
the
left-wing confession you say i'm i did
not overeat this month
i'm sorry my fault my fault through my
most grievous
fault i i did not over drink i only
drank a little bit this month i'm sorry
i didn't pursue my appetites to their
fullest
extent now maybe you're saying michael
you're reading too much into
lizzo's apology for going on a diet to
her fans
i don't think so she actually had to to
publish a second apology which was
far uh she wasn't wearing as much
clothing in this one so it was
you know maybe just listen to this i
don't know who knows
she had to give this second apology to
offer the philosophical basis
for the reason she apologized in the
first place
your body is perfectly yours even if it
ain't perfect
to anybody else if you only knew the
complexities your body possesses you
would be so proud of it
i'm so proud of you for making it this
far
in a society that gives us a head start
into self-loathing
that hands us a dysmorphic mirror and
leaves us desperate to catch up with who
we think we should be
i've spent so much time in this body and
i am no different than you
still struggling to find balance still
trying to mend my relationship with food
my anxiety my back fat it gets easier
i've spent my hardest days trying to
love me if i have any advice
it is to eat drink move
rest your job is to grow
your job is to figure it out along the
way regardless of what i or any
so-called expert says you love you
and i hope you remember that no
no no whatever
philosophical view that is no not that
you should not uh hate yourself you
should not hate your body
you should not be proud of your body
either you should not
consider your body to be the be all and
end all of your life
both both of those things are pretty bad
both of those things can lead to eating
disorders by the way
obsessing obsessing all the time about
your body whether
that you're too fat or that you're too
skinny or then whatever
those can lead to anorexia they can lead
to morbid obesity
the the problem with this is
this point of view this liberalism i
guess
tells you to focus above all on yourself
what you
want what your appetites are how you
feel that you want to identify
frankly even if it has not talked about
another dysmorphic
ideology the idea that your physical
body has nothing to do with your true
self
which is you see this expressed most
clearly in gender ideology that you know
you can look like a man but actually
deep down
be a woman and you just keep saying what
am i what am i who am i what am i me me
me i me my i me my
the key is not to think more of yourself
it's to
to it's not to think less of yourself
for that matter
it's to think of yourself less
focus on other things there are other
things out there in the world
and the way this breaks down then is
when you kind of get out of this
childish liberalism then you can either
go the conservative route and say okay
there's something outside of myself
and it looks kind of like this moral
order and it's kind of looks like these
traditional things and it looks like the
seven virtues and you know
the devices and don't do the vices and
okay right and then the other way you
can go
is the woke view that that leftism
offers a coherent moral framework
it's uh i'm sorry it's internally
consistent it's
objectively incoherent though right it's
when you look at it
it's like a completely inverted moral
framework and this you do you
do whatever you want if it feels good do
it liberalism in the middle
that doesn't make any sense and and the
conservatives who think well let's just
go
for that that's stable that's a truce
that it's not
you have to pick a side and what the
obviously the liberal establishment has
trended woke
for a hundred years it's been going on
for so long and if you think
that as we're getting a more liberal
government again
that that you're going to fight that by
retreating to this
lame meek liberalism it ain't going to
work buddy you need to
you need to be able to say things say
moral truth say political truths
actually have some courage actually say
people should do this sort of thing
they shouldn't do this sort of thing
that's not un-american that's not
illiberal even that's how politics is
and has always been